[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
en eeuu la demora del presidente trump
en conceder la victoria de las
elecciones presidenciales crea un
escenario de transición complicado sin
precedentes en la historia del país
revisamos cómo se lleva a cabo el
proceso de entrega del poder
brasil es el segundo país con más
muertes por kobe 19 en américa
allí los pueblos indígenas no sólo deben
luchar por acceder a los servicios de
salud en sus remotos territorios sino
además por mantener viva sus tradiciones
que algunas veces van en contra de las
medidas de salubridad contra la pandemia
en colombia se cumplen 4 años de la
firma del acuerdo de paz entre el
gobierno de juan manuel santos y la
guerrilla de las farc el pacto que puso
fin a el conflicto más antiguo del
continente americano y le valió a santos
el nobel de paz pero la violencia parece
haber recrudecido les explicamos por qué
empezamos en eeuu la demora del
presidente de donald trump en conceder
la victoria a joe biden elevó las dudas
sobre una transición pacífica del poder
el 20 de enero como es tradición en eeuu
algo que no tiene precedentes en la
historia del país que establece la
constitución en tales circunstancias les
explicamos
la transición del poder entre dos
presidentes en 2016 barack obama le
entregó el poder pacíficamente a donald
trump
pero la llegada de joe biden a la casa
blanca el 20 de enero de 2021 está
forjándose de manera diferente la
transición entre dos presidentes está
anclada en la tradición aunque
legalmente la ley de transición
presidencial de 1963 fue creada para
facilitar la llegada de una nueva
administración para que eso pase la
administración de servicios generales a
cargo de manejar las agencias federales
tiene que dar luz verde para liberar los
fondos al presidente electo ya su equipo
por hasta 10 millones de dólares pero su
directora emily marfil elegida por champ
en 2017 retrasó la transición oficial
del poder cuando el presidente se negó a
reconocer su derrota
la administración de servicios generales
determina el candidato aparentemente
exitoso una vez el ganador es claro
según el proceso establecido en la
constitución lo que significó
dificultades para el equipo de bailén
para planear su primer día en la casa
blanca- la administración llegan te ha
logrado establecer una fuerza de trabajo
contra el cubo 19 pero se le negó el
acceso a agencias federales e
información estratégica acabo de llamar
a clinton a felicitarme
ningún candidato presidencial moderno se
ha negado a reconocer su derrota desde
que las concesiones formales se hicieron
costumbre en 1896 y tampoco un
presidente saliente se ha negado a
asistir a la toma de posición de su
sucesor en 1992 george bush padre perdió
su reelección contra bill clinton el
presidente saliente le dejó una carta de
apoyo el día de la toma de posiciones
estableciendo otra tradición
presidencial moderna usted será nuestro
presidente cuando lee esta carta le
deseo lo mejor le deseo buenas cosas a
su familia su éxito es el éxito de
nuestro país
su amp sin embargo es conocido por no
mantener las normas presidenciales y
cuando yo vaivén reciba el poder el 20
de enero su esposa trascenderá en la
historia como primera dama se convertirá
en la primera esposa de un presidente en
mantener su trabajo actual
también el esposo de la vicepresidenta
electa kamala harris hará historia será
el primer segundo caballero en la
historia de la nación conozcamos más
sobre los compañeros de vida del nuevo
dúo presidencial en el siguiente informe
una nueva primera dama y por primera vez
un segundo caballero jill biden y
douglas en job pasan a la historia
política de eeuu jill biden es una
profesora de 69 años y se desempeña como
maestra inglés en un centro de estudios
superiores un cargo que quiere mantener
durante su etapa como primera dama
voy a seguir enseñando es importante y
quiero que los profesores valoren a los
educadores y conozcan su contribución
tenía 24 años cuando conoció joe biden
tres años antes él había perdido de su
primera esposa e hija en un accidente
automovilístico jill dijo que si después
de rechazarlo tres veces aquí estaba en
estos niños pequeños que habían perdido
a su madre y a su hermana y tenía que
asegurarme de que este matrimonio iba a
funcionar
juntos construyeron la familia como su
esposo la primera dama entrante ha
prometido impulsar a eeuu jardines como
se puede formar una familia rota de la
misma manera que lo haces con toda una
nación anexión hou douglas en hop abrazo
a kamala harris cuando llegó el
resultado la pareja había salido a
correr abogado de profesión ha hecho una
fuerte campaña por el éxito de su socio
baile
mi esposa mi amada esposa
kamala harris hija de inmigrantes
viviendo un ejemplo de lo posible
viviendo el sueño americano
apareció como su segundo chef en este
programa de cocina
e intervino en el escenario en su
defensa cuando se interrumpió un evento
de campaña dice que está contento de
haber dejado su carrera en suspenso por
el bien de su socio y tenemos una buena
pareja al entrar y creo que salimos como
ya sabes
el primer segundo caballero se asoció
con la primera primera dama para
mantener su trabajo diario la pareja
conforman un elenco de apoyo
revolucionario para la presidencia de
2020 vamos a brasil la pandemia del
coronavirus representa un doble desafío
para las comunidades indígenas del
gigante sudamericano por un lado
conseguir atención médica en territorios
inmensos y casi aislados es todo un reto
pero además los yanomamis un pueblo que
vive en el norte del país se oponen a
los entierros de los fallecidos por kobe
19 y luchan para poder realizar los
ritos fúnebres según sus tradiciones
veamos el informe de nuestras
corresponsales
juniors es un líder yanomami que vive
entre boavista la capital de roraima y
su reserva indígena que está cerca de la
frontera con venezuela al menos nueve
indígenas de su etnia ha muerto con el
hobbit 19 y hay una decena de
fallecimientos sospechosos
y después hay que crear el cuerpo es
todo un procedimiento hay que pedir
permiso tiene que ser nombrada una
persona que durante dos años se encarga
de las cenizas y después se entierran
las cenizas internas así en total 12
yanomamis fueron sepultados en los
cementerios de boavista su cultura prevé
la incineración y un ritual complejo que
puede durar hasta dos años por seguridad
las autoridades sanitarias prohibieron
transportar los restos hasta las aldeas
indígenas
los yanomami hicieron contacto con los
brasileños hace relativamente poco
tiempo no entienden el porqué del
entierro es un impacto cultural muy
grande cultura
estas son las tumbas de dos bebés
yanomami con sospecha de gobi en budista
no hay horno crematorio y las
autoridades prefieren esperar tres años
antes de la exhumación para evitar
cualquier riesgo de contagio para los
yanomamis es un tiempo demasiado largo
tú
pero las madres están todavía muy
desesperadas y tristes están en las
reservas a la espera de que les
devuelvan el cuerpo de sus niños a
cúcuta
a su crianza en julio france24 acompañó
la misión kobe 19 de las fuerzas armadas
brasileñas a la reserva yanomami
habitada por 28.000 personas hayan
sabido cúcuta y detonar el ciclo sabemos
que los cuerpos de los yanomami tienen
que regresar y que el siglo precisa ser
cerrados pero aconsejamos que esto se
haga con seguridad cuando realmente no
haya riesgo de llevar esta infección
para el resto de la comunidad está en
ciudad comunidad
el gobierno de brasil costeará la
exhumación y el traslado de los cuerpos
cuando llegue el momento mientras las
madres yanomami aguardan y se debaten
entre el dolor y la esperanza
en colombia se cumplen 4 años de la
firma del acuerdo de paz entre el
gobierno del entonces presidente juan
manuel santos y la guerrilla de las farc
en el teatro colon de bogotá el acuerdo
que llevó a la desmovilización de los
integrantes de ese grupo y puso fin al
conflicto con la guerrilla más antigua
del continente americano pero el país
parece estar lejos de la paz con más de
60 masacres en lo corrido de 2020 la
violencia ha aumentado en las regiones
abandonadas por las farc en medio de la
disputa de otros grupos ilegales por el
control de dichos territorios el nombre
de las farc ep
ofrezco sinceramente perdón a todas las
víctimas del conflicto en colombia se
firmó la paz dos veces la primera el 26
de septiembre de 2016 en la ciudad de
cartagena
pero días después el 2 de octubre los
ciudadanos le dijeron no al acuerdo con
la guerrilla de las farc negociado
durante cuatro años en la habana cuba
él no llegó en la misma semana en el que
el comité noruego del premio nobel
anunciaba al mundo que ese acuerdo le
valía al entonces presidente juan manuel
santos el nobel de la paz
por lo que el gobierno santos se vio
obligado a renegociarlo incluyendo
algunas solicitudes de la oposición
encabezada por el expresidente álvaro
uribe vélez
la segunda firma se llevó a cabo el 24
de noviembre de 2016 en el teatro colon
de bogotá
las farc y el gobierno prometieron
entonces un nuevo comienzo tras más de
50 años de guerra un reinicio
esperanzador pues el texto acordado puso
a las víctimas en el centro de la
discusión por primera vez y creó un
sistema de verdad justicia reparación y
no repetición al que serían sometidos
los culpables de esos delitos en la
justicia transicional pero en el cuarto
aniversario de la firma de este acuerdo
la anhelada paz no se ha consolidado un
informe del instituto creo que reveló
que al terminar el tercer año desde la
firma del pacto sólo el 25 por ciento de
las disposiciones se había implementado
completamente el aniversario coincide
con un alarmante incremento de las
masacres y asesinatos de líderes
sociales y de ex combatientes de las
farc e incluso la organización de
naciones unidas ha expresado su
preocupación por los asesinatos de los
guerrilleros que entregaron sus armas
nosotros hicimos dejación de las armas
creyendo en la palabra el estado y al
día de hoy 236 de nuestros compañeros
han caído asesinados en diferentes
departamentos del país algunos sectores
culpan al actual gobierno de iván duque
sin embargo el actual mandatario asegura
estar comprometido con el acuerdo una de
las razones del incremento de la
violencia radica en que el estado no
tomó el control rápidamente de las zonas
abandonadas por las farc lo que hizo que
organizaciones criminales de algunos
disidentes de la guerrilla comenzaran a
disputar su control para tomar a su vez
control de las rutas de narcotráfico con
los disidentes más los integrantes de
otra guerrilla auto denominada ejército
de liberación nacional y las bandas
criminales colombia tiene hoy alrededor
de 7.000 hombres ilegalmente armados sin
embargo gracias al acuerdo de paz 13.000
guerrilleros se desmovilizaron y algunos
de ellos se integraron con éxito a la
vida política al ocupar sillas en el
congreso y el gobierno de duke ha
impulsado la reincorporación de los ex
combatientes con proyectos productivos
que benefician a cerca de 4600 ex
insurgentes
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho el coronavirus y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]